Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we're gonna get some wisdom,
because we are going to
review some sage advice.
Yeah, we asked you
what the best advice
you've ever received was,
and that was because,
we were asked that question by Stanna US,
who asked us on Twitter,
" What is the best advice
someone has ever given you?
With the most impact on your life."
And we were like, you know what?
That's a good question.
We'll answer that.
We're gonna try to answer that,
but we sent that question back to you
and got all the advice that you thought
was the most impactful
in your entire life,
and we're gonna go through and evaluate
whether or not it's good advice.
We're just gonna go through
and take the advice that
you've taken to heart to heart
and discuss.
And discuss, was at the
end of your sentence?
And discuss.
We're going to discuss it.
It, it.
I think it is unnecessary
in that sentence.
I think we need to put a disclaimer
at the top of this thing,
so just bear with me--
Are you gonna do a Prop 65 thing?
No, what I'm--
This podcast has been known
by the state of California
to potentially cause cancer.
I saw that on my frickin fiber supplement.
What?
Yeah.
Was it the bottle or was the pills
that you're swallowing?
It was the bag of just...
Is it psyllium husk?
Yeah.
Fiber that I take if I
need to regulate myself,
which I don't take much anymore.
So if you ate the bag,
you might get cancer.
No, it had a sticker on it,
that I've never seen before
and I got like the natural stuff
that's supposed to be the purest
is just 100% psyllium husk,
and then all of a sudden
there's this thing,
this sticker and it's like Prop 65
but it doesn't say this substance
or substance in this bag has been known
to cause cancer in the city of California.
It says, see Prop 65.gov/food
or whatever the address.
I'm like what?
Why?
So it's not talking about the container?
I think it's just like you should--
It's talking about--
You should know about what foods--
The supplements.
To watch out for.
I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
No.
Sorry I brought it up.
I was just gonna say,
advice is a certain type of opinion.
And as you know,
opinions are like buttholes,
everybody's got one
and most of them stink.
So that tells me that,
advice is like a butthole farting
in your specific direction.
Is an implication that like--
I would say unsolicited advice.
I've got an opinion on
something you should do.
So you got to be careful
that you're sniffing the fart of somebody
that is worthy of sniffing.
I think unsolicited
advice is like a butthole
but solicited advice--
No, no opinions are like a butthole.
But advice is a type of opinion.
Advice is a fart directed at you.
But if I ask you for your
opinion on something,
it's not like a butthole anymore.
If I give you advice.
Unsolicited.
Then yeah, you need to evaluate
the source of the advice,
which we're not gonna do here.
We're gonna take everybody--
I think solicited opinions
are just like a whole ass,
just not ass.
It's like,
but the butthole, you know?
I'm saying that in it,
but I'm also saying that,
advice in general is an
opinion directed at you.
It's an implication like,
this is my opinion on what
you should do with yourself,
how you should conduct yourself.
Yeah.
So we're in dangerous territory here.
You got to watch the farts you sniffing.
But we're not giving any advice,
we're just evaluating advice
that people have been giving.
So we're not showing our asses at all.
And we pick stuff that's
resonated with us.
I think this is gonna be
an uplifting conversation.
And it better be because it needs to last
for three more weeks.
'Cause I hate to break it to you.
Oh, yeah.
Dear Ear Biscuiteer,
but we're gonna go dark,
for the next three weeks.
We're taking our summer break.
We're taking a break.
Three weeks with no Ear Biscuits,
but there's a lot of Ear Biscuits
that you can go--
Go back to.
Go back and listen to.
There's also, I hate to say it,
I mean there's also other podcasts.
That is a thing you could also listen to.
Just over the next three weeks,
just go back through our podcasts.
I'm sure there's
something that you missed.
I hear that people listen
to them multiple times,
because they're doing stuff
when they're listening to it
and you kind of fall in--
You only get--
And out of--
50% or less.
Yeah.
Anyway, meaning you're listening intently.
Yeah, I probably need to listen to them
over the next three weeks 'cause--
Why don't you do that?
I'm sure I missed some stuff.
Have you ever listened to
an episode of Ear Biscuits?
I listen to myself when I'm speaking.
And sometimes I listen to
you when you're speaking.
Right.
But no, I have not listened
back to an Ear Biscuit
in a long time, maybe ever.
I think when we first
started making these--
Maybe the interviews,
maybe I was listening
to a couple of those.
I would listen to them
in order to figure out
what it is we wanted to do.
Yeah.
It's quite a time commitment
to listen to yourself for over an hour.
When you're already there.
Yeah, if you put it on
double speed or something,
you really can't.
Then it just sounds weird.
You really don't learn that much.
You miss all the emotion.
I think it's working well enough for me
not to try to make it better.
We're gonna answer that question ourselves
before the break.
Not before the break
that we just talked about
the three week break,
but before the break where we do our ad.
What are you talking about?
We're gonna answer the question.
Just talk.
Oh we're gonna answer the question
about what our best piece of advice was.
When, right now?
Yeah.
Okay, well then just do it.
You talking about a break
like we're about to take one.
Well, we're gonna take one eventually.
Eventually.
But not the three week break.
When you start talking about the break--
The ad break.
When I listen back to our podcast,
here's the one thing I've learned,
don't talk about a break,
If you're not gonna take it.
'Cause then people think
you're about to take it.
Yeah, yeah.
Eventually, yeah, we'll take one.
We're not about to take a break.
Eventually.
We're still doing the show.
We haven't even gotten started,
you talking about taking a break.
I have some advice that I have used.
I just feel myself saying it,
and we say it all the time.
"It's what you make it."
It's what you make it.
And we always say it like that,
"It's what you make it."
Like you're quoting someone?
Right.
Yeah, I think that's..
The thing that's
been driving me nuts
is not remembering who gave us the advice,
but I'll tell you what I do know.
I don't know who gave it.
It was in the context of a
person talking about marriage,
" It's what you make it."
But I've used it in many,
many different arenas.
You know me and my arena
Just life in general.
It's what you make it.
It's up to you now,
as we will see when we
get into some of these
other questions.
That ain't true.
It's not completely up to you,
but it's good.
When you think about a situation
that you're entering into,
and I think the thing the guy
was talking about was like,
how do you have a good marriage?
And it's just like,
"It's what you make it."
" Is this something Greg said in college?"
No, 'cause Greg said,
"You know what you know,
you don't learn anything."
When I was getting ready
to study for a test.
Yeah, clear ulterior motives
in that piece of sage wisdom.
Which I gotta say,
while I have used that
conveniently for my own purposes,
I do not think it's good advice,
because I do actually
think you learn things.
I hope it ain't true.
I think you learn things.
I think there was capacity for learning.
I think I've learned some things, yeah.
But I think it was--
"It's what you make it."
At of the fall retreats.
Are you sure you're not
getting it confused with,
"It's part of it?"
As a Dale Earnhardt quote?
That's part of it.
When it's like that's racing,
that's what Earnhardt said.
I say it out a lot too.
When he would do stuff that people didn't.
He would drive in a way
that he would clanging
and banging up against the other cars
and get a little rowdy
and be like, "That's racing.
I think that's a Earnhardt quote.
I don't know.
It'd be a Waltraud quote.
I've never watched an entire NASCAR race.
You're saying 'That's racing"
is the racing version of
"That's part of it."
Yeah.
You're not saying
that Dale Earnhardt came up with
"That part of it."
Because I think that
a caveman came up with
"That part of it."
As soon as language was a thing,
someone said, "That's part of it."
And that's not really advice,
It's just kind of a saying.
Right.
Life is what you make it.
But, "It's what you make it" is advice.
cause I feel like advice is--
It's implying a state of mind.
Well, it's also advice--
Focus on what you can control.
Is an opportunity to do something, right?
Or to not do something.
But there is a response that
is intended from advice.
Every moment of your
life you never get back.
But I think that it was at that
What about that?
Fall retreat.
One of those fall retreats
that we went to as students,
involved a campus crusade,
and the guy who was speaking there,
and I think he was doing
a talk on marriage.
He also talked about genital warts.
I mean, that's one of the
things that I remember vividly.
I wasn't there for that.
Where there photos?
No, no.
His opening salvo--
You getting this confused
with health class.
Like coach Bunch
No, no, no
Teaching you about it
I specifically remember it.
He told a story about a
man who did something,
like had promiscuous sex
or cheated on his wife or something.
And it was just like,
and that man got genital warts.
And I was like, whoa,
we're going here?
Alright, okay.
What does that mean?
And then he was like,
"And that man was me."
And then it's like, whoa.
What.
Which is you got
genital warts.
And so --
I was not there for this.
So okay.
I would have remembered that.
You would remembered that.
You think he was like,
"And genital warts are what you make them"
What?
No, because the way that they
did the fall retreats is--
If you get the warts that is.
It was a guy who--
It's what you make it.
There was a guy,
it was always a guy.
Who spoke the entire weekend.
And so his opening talk was genital warts.
And he had us by the
genital warts at that point.
It was like whatever this guy says,
don't miss any of the main talks, right?
"Cause he opened with genital warts.
Mm-hmm.
And then he went to
just talking about relationships
and marriage or something,
and I kind of swear he said,
"It's what you make it."
It didn't seem revolutionary at the time,
and I don't necessarily think
that it is revolutionary,
but the question was,
that is impacted you the most.
And I just find myself in
situations all the time,
and I'm like,
"It's what you make it."
It has been helpful as a joke,
but also as a reality.
"Cause it helps you focus
on what you can control
in any given situation.
Yeah.
As opposed to the parts that you can't.
I think we'll come back to that.
I think there's some advice,
it's not just, is the advice good,
but who is the advice for?
The advice that has always
resonated with me is,
"Anything worth doing
is worth doing right."
But that's a bit problematic
for a guy like me
that gets over focused on
the rightness of things
and going about them in the right way--
Cause you might not do
something if you don't think
you can do it right.
Yeah, there's some fear and trepidation,
If that rings in my ears too much.
And then it's never clear cut.
I'd like to believe that it is,
and say okay, this is perfected,
I can move on.
You gotta balance all these things.
It's what you make it.
Nana's version of that was,
"Don't half-ass it."
Right.
Which we've talked about.
I've had a hard time.
There's not a lot of mottos
that ring in my head that were
wants just pieces of advice.
I remember when we were going on a trip
to shoot some videos,
a guy told me a guy me,
a guy who I admire he said,
"Hey just remember,
it's better to have a good
story than a good time."
And I kind of like that because,
we're trying to make a...
If you're in a...
and I've talked about
this before on the show,
if you're in a situation,
and it's sucks,
you're like, "well, at least
I can tell a story about it
because I have a podcast."
Or you have friends or
people who are listening.
And yeah, I like telling a good story.
So that's always helped
give me perspective
when I'm going through something crappy.
But it's a little bit weird to say it
before you're in that situation.
Well, especially because,
I think that being present is actually--
Yeah.
A better advice.
I understand, if you're going
through a difficult time,
it's just better to have a
good story than a good time.
If you're in the middle like,
it's one of those crazy vacations
where everything's going wrong.
This sucks but at least,
if I live to tell it,
I will tell it.
And usually what I say
in those situations is,
"Man this makes a great story."
I'm up shits creek without a paddle but,
at least it's a good story.
Like you said,
especially when you have
a place to tell the story.
But I don't think that,
if I'm getting ready
to go do something fun,
"better to have a good
story than a good time"
is good advice,
because what about the joy
Yeah.
That is available for me in the present?
I don't think it was great
advice in that sense.
But I still really like it.
What about,
"Remember who you are."
Parents send their kids
out into some something
that they're gonna do
and they come to the front door
and they're like,
"Hey, hey, hey, remember who you are."
Have you ever said that
one of your children?
Ah, sometimes I'd be like,
" Remember you're a Neal."
And what is that supposed to communicate?
Don't embarrass me.
I don't say that often.
I don't find myself every giving these
quotable pieces of advice to my kids.
Yeah, not quotable,
not bite size is more.
But what I am guilty of,
and I know you're just
as guilty of it as I am,
is giving advice in general to our kids.
It's actually something that
Jessie and I have talked
a lot about is that,
sometimes we get into a
conversation with our kids,
they're just telling us about their day.
They're telling us
about something they did
or something they're going to do.
And then there's like this
dad button that gets pressed
and the dad button responds will like
And you get this response, now,
"Well, if you're gonna do that,
think about this.
Or when did that happen?
What did you learn then, blah blah blah."
It's like--
Unsolicited.
If you've got a friend
who talks like that,
like every single time
they tell you something,
you tell them something,
they give you advice about it.
That's not--
What do you think I am, a screw up?
I'm telling you this
so that we can connect,
because I thought you
might find it interesting
because you might be able
to add something to it,
or you might be able to respond
to it with a perspective.
Yeah.
But not to then tell me
what I should have done differently,
or what I should have kept in mind,
and I do that with my kids too often.
I find when my kids talk
about their friends,
things that are happening
with their friends,
I am apparently filtering the conversation
through an analysis of,
"Do I approve of their friends?"
'Cause--
Oh, yeah.
Your friends is so powerful.
There's probably a piece
of advice in there.
"You are who you hang out with."
It's probably a catchier version of that?
But I think that I filter
things through that platitude,
so then, when they're just
talking about their day
or something that happened I'm like,
"Well you know if you're
that type of person,
if they do that then that's
not really a true friend.
A true friend is someone who
blah blah blah blah blah."
I end up analyzing and trying to protect.
But I guess you wanna get to a
point where they're actually,
it's solicited advice.
My kids are asking,
"Hey I'm in this situation
or this person said this to me,
I don't know how to respond or you know."
Well, and if they don't do that,
I think that there and I
don't have this perfected.
I don't even have it
immediately understood,
but the thing that I'm trying
to do now is ask questions,
in a way that's not like a detective,
not like a leading question.
So I seem like I'm manipulating,
but okay, I'm having this conversation.
There is something that I feel like I need
to communicate about this.
Because I still do have advice,
I have been around longer,
I have a perspective on this,
And I think I got a
little wisdom about this.
And our kids left to their own devices,
don't ask for advices.
Right.
And so then I'll ask a question.
My kids are smart enough to know
what I'm getting at,
but at least it doesn't come across like,
"Well, did you know,
here is the thing that
I'm going to tell you."
But it's more like,
"Have you thought about this?
Or how you feeling about it?"
At least it gets them talking.
And maybe you get someplace
where they come to a conclusion.
I don't know,
It's tough being a dad.
But, we don't have to come
up with all the advice,
we've got some great advice from people.
We're gonna start going through it.
But first,
we're just going to gently advise you
to check out mythical.com.
We say it every week,
but every week there's
a little something new.
There's sales going on.
There's stuff going on.
You think we got hoodies,
you think we got T-shirts?
Yeah, we got that.
But we got lots of other stuff
like pins and stickers and--
Well, and we've got
the whole Feel Good
Mythical Morning ensemble,
that we came up with.
We had the Feel Good
Mythical Morning Hoodie,
but now they got the Feel
Good Mythical Morning T-shirt.
We got the Feel Good
Mythical Morning sticker
and enamel pin.
So if you wanna feel good.
That's our advice.
"Feel good."
If it feels good, do it.
And if you need some help with that,
just go to Mythical.com.
Okay, let's get started.
Sometimes I tell my kids,
"Don't think just do."
It's probably.
And ironic--
In what context?
Usually when they're standing
on the edge of a pool,
and they're afraid to
jump in because it's cold.
I was gonna say in like
an athletic context?
Yeah.
That's great advice.
Because the thinking and
the doing is supposed
to be happening in sync.
If you're thinking, the guy's
already gone around you.
Somebody else has jumped in the pool.
It's also ironic because
Before you.
It's not what I want them to
do in their non athletic lives.
Which is the vast majority of their life.
I'm not cutting on my kids.
Yeah, it did.
Your kids are non athletic?
My kids are not sports minded.
Yeah, but I wouldn't say
they're non athletic,
they just might not be
like super into sports.
But if you threw like a hot dog at them,
they probably catch it.
Don't you think?
I'll test that.
Try that
I'll test that today.
That's the ultimate test of athleticism.
Throw a hot dog straight from the fridge
right at your child's face.
And if it hits him in the face,
hopefully they're smart.
Because they're not athletic.
They're not athletic.
Okay.
Give me some advice.
Ariana bearscivilles on Twitter.
My grandmother--
It's bearskvlls but the U is a V.
Yeah, I was just trying to be phonetic.
My grandmother always used to tell me,
"look towards the sunshine,
and the shadows will fall behind you."
That's true from like
a physics standpoint.
Every time the sun is out,
it makes me feel like
she's watching over me
and making sure I'm taking care of myself.
Isn't it so sweet
if you have these memories of grandparents
or someone that means something to you,
that even if they passed,
that they passed along something
that can echo like them?
For her to be so positive.
Look towards the sunshine.
Actually, be positive
and the shadows will fall behind you.
I consider myself a
generally positive person,
but i think is more of a
coping mechanism with me.
It's like, oh gosh.
If I can convince myself that
when things are not going well,
'cause that does happen,
I'll feel better if I can minimize.
But I've met some people that
seem more like genuinely positive people.
They have a gift for it.
They can turn from the shadow
and see the sunshine in a moment.
Maybe they're just so good at applying
this kind of advice that
they're secretly catastrophizing but.
The advice is for people
who don't have a natural gift at it,
because they don't need the advice.
So it does involve you.
You can make a choice in any situation
what you're going to focus on.
Mm-hmm.
And how you're gonna see it,
how you're gonna process it.
I mean, this advice
has been given in a lot
of different contexts.
You've got keep on the sunny side of life,
that great song.
But then Locke and I actually had
this conversation the other day,
and talking about...
And I'm sure that you've been
having similar conversations
with your teenage kids and all your kids.
But I think that COVID has
been especially frustrating
for teenagers because,
you just think about
what your life was like
when you were 16,
and to have all these
restrictions put on--
You have so much life to live.
Where you can go, yeah.
You haven't lived most of it.
Right, and you're like oh--
It's frustrating.
The summer of my 16th year is, what?
I gotta wear masks if I
wanna be around my friends
and they thought and
probably be outside with them
and I to ask them questions about,
where they've been and where
their families have been.
This is incredibly frustrating,
especially considering the fact that,
if a teenager gets the Coronavirus,
that mean the chances of
even them even knowing
they've got it, is pretty small, right?
Is this not going to
affect them personally,
so it's almost completely,
selfless thing that they have to do.
And so, we've had a lot
of conversations about
how difficult this has been.
In the in the way that I gave
him some advice the other day
'cause I was like--
Look towards the sunshine
and the shadows will fall behind you.
Well, that's what I should have said.
But what I said is like,
and this is not as good of advice as this,
'cause it's not as simple.
But I was like,
"You're going through something right now.
And I can write a story about it,
and I can write two
different scripts, right?
And one script is that
this is really difficult
and really restrictive,
and your parents are
taking this too seriously,
and all the negative
things that you can see."
Mm-hmm.
But then there's
the positive side of the script,
which is when you look back on this,
you'd be like,
I lived through this really weird time
and it made me reevaluate my friendships.
And we kind of went through
like all the positive way
that the things that you could focus on.
It's like your parents are
healthy, you're healthy,
nobody that we know has gotten this.
There's not other health
conditions that we're already...
No one in our family is immunocompromised.
You start sort of counting
all your blessings
and the things that you
have been privileged to,
the position that you're in.
And you're like, oh, okay, that helps.
You turn towards the positive.
And then I was like,
because your circumstances
are not gonna change, right?
We're gonna be in this for a while,
and if you're expecting me
to do something to make it okay for you,
or you're expecting your
friends to do something.
No, the only thing that you can do
is you can write your own script,
you can turn towards the sunshine,
turn away from the darkness.
And I'm kind of giving myself that advice
as I give it to him because,
this has been difficult
for everybody, right?
But to say like,
all right, where can I be grateful?
What can I focus on?
Because I have a whole
lot to be thankful for.
And when I do that,
all of a sudden it's like, okay, yeah,
it's truly helpful.
The Black Sheep responded
to our prompt and said,
"Life changing advice was
to always remember Sonder
S-O-N-D-E-R,
before getting upset at somebody
else over petty things."
And then she put the definition of sonder,
which I had never heard that definition.
Oh, I actually had this pulled up.
Not.
Sonder,
it is a company.
No.
That is like Airbnb,
but people never live in the homes,
but it's like a curated
hotel in a home experience
that no one ever lived in.
That ain't what we're talking.
Right, 'cause it was as
a term coined in 2012
by John Koring or Koenig,
whose project "The Dictionary
of Obscure Sorrows"
aims to come up with
new words for emotions
that currently lack words.
Mm-hmm.
And this one is inspired by German sonder,
which means special and French sonder
which means to probe.
And his definition is,
the profound feeling of
realizing that everyone,
including strangers passed in the street,
has a life as complex as one's own,
which they are constantly living,
despite one's personal
lack of awareness of it.
Go back to the definition she posted.
It's a little more succinct.
Sonder noun.
The realization that each
random passerby is living a life
as vivid and complex as your own.
I love this.
I wanna remember this word.
Imma say it three times.
Sonder, sonder, sonder.
I've got it.
I'm doubtful but.
Behind every face,
there's a story.
Look over sonder.
And that is something
that we've talked about.
When you interact with people,
you never know what's
going on in their life.
I tend to immediately think about
seeing strangers get angry like a road--
On the internet.
Like a road rage situation.
Okay, well, we can talk
about the internet too.
But when you see somebody
or you read their comment or whatever,
it's tough not to just
react to how it impacts you
or how it strikes you.
Even if it's just a passerby
that it is not impacting you at all.
But it's a good exercise to say,
and there's a story being lived out there.
That person is going through something.
And when somebody does something
that's like a head scratcher, or worse,
that person is lashing out in anger.
Just stop and sonderise it,
say you know what,
I've been really angry before
and sometimes it's not justified
but there were other
things going on in my life
that I knew about
or couldn't put my finger on,
just to have a little pause for compassion
And also when you are about
to get angry at someone
for something.
Mm-hmm.
Right, when they say
or do something meant
unintentionally, intentionally
or otherwise.
When you think oh, it's
just empathy, right?
It's putting yourself
in somebody else's shoes
and just understanding that yeah.
And they also are worried about
the way that they look and
they sound to the same degree
that you are right?
Everyone's a bit obsessed with themselves.
I know that I'm gonna
make mistakes in life,
I'm gonna wrong people.
I'm gonna place my needs
above other people.
I'm gonna do things that I regret
and then I'm sorry for.
And I'm gonna do things
that are also misinterpreted
and can be misinterpreted a lot worse
than they actually were.
Mm-hmm.
And I want people to give
me the benefit of the doubt
when entering into a situation
and a dialogue with me about
whatever mistake I made
or potentially made.
It goes a long way for
people to believe the bests.
I don't know if you meant
this when you said it,
but it struck me in this way.
Mm-hmm.
Or it seems like you said this,
I don't know if that's what you intended.
Is an example of opening a conversation.
It's not like, that is the worst thing.
That's stupid or that's ignorant,
or it could just be a mistake
or a misunderstanding.
Now believing the best in some situations,
I think the best that you can
believe is still pretty bad
in a certain situation.
Of course.
There are people who do bad things
Like I said, people should
be held accountably.
And they do it on purpose.
This is not about excusing anyone
No.
For their behavior.
In general believing the best in people
and applying that filter,
whenever I find myself getting up in arms.
That saying implies that
you want to attack, right?
And I think we get to that
with another piece of advice,
so maybe I'll leave it at that.
But I do wanna just remember sonder
and I think it's a good...
For some reason, because
I don't live in New York
and we visit New York City.
I always think of that environment
'cause you're walking around
and you're seeing so many faces.
That's what I picture with sonder.
Is that like I'm on a street corner,
I'm always overwhelmed when
I go back in a good way.
"Well look at all these people just moving
with the traffic lights."
Behind every set of eyes there's a story.
There's something in that
that kinda makes me swell up with,
like pride for be a human.
There's a vivid experience there
that I know nothing about.
Yeah, I think about that
when I'm on elevators
with people sometimes.
It's a fun practice.
I think it's a good habit to cultivate.
And then I don't talk to them,
I don't say anything.
Yeah,
it could be problematic
being the elevator talker,
but it is a good habit.
I think it puts you in your place.
When you see somebody say,
"I wonder what their story is."
And then it might be fun
just to make something up,
just in your own mind,
but as long as you don't convince yourself
that's them and then say,
"I can't believe that
you left the gate open
on the tiger cage at the zoo."
That's one of my favorite things about
that Duplass brothers book.
Oh, yeah.
Is how they will sit in an
airport next to each other
and they'll see somebody or a couple
and they begin basically
saying who they are.
Writing a screenplay.
Let's get to another one, sonder.
Miranda Lemke, mythicalemke.
"Always check air and
fluid in your vehicle
before going on a long trip.
My dad, when I was learning
how to drive told me that."
Oh yeah.
I love this, yeah.
My father-in-law...
When Christy and I were dating
when we were first married,
and we would visit,
I would after him be like,
"Hey nice to see you," in greeting.
One of the first things he would do,
I would look back over my shoulder,
if we were bringing in our luggage,
and he'd have the hood popped on the car.
That just arrived?
You couldn't do that 'cause it'd be hot,
It'd be too hot.
You can't check the oil when it's hot.
But I do remember finding
him very early on,
and he would have popped the hood
and he's checking the oil.
And a lot of times he'd be like,
"Christy, you haven't been
checking the oil in the car.
The oil is low."
And I started learning
before we would go there
that I would check the oil at the house,
'cause I knew that he would do it.
He would look 14 point
Jiffy Lube inspection
at Bobby's house.
Well, and especially when you got a car,
because my dad was very
committed to the Dodge brand
for like throughout my entire childhood.
Dodge Chrysler.
We had to Dodge Dynastys,
we had the Dodge Intrepid,
there was a New Yorker.
You were excited about that Intrepid.
But every single one of
these cars without fail,
first of all,
if you got a Dodge the
transmission is going out
at 100,000 miles or earlier,
but it's not it's not making it past that.
And then the second thing is,
it starts burning oil at some point.
It burns oil to the point that
you have to keep oil in your car.
A court.
And so I remember in college
driving that Intrepid
and just checking the
oil and filling it up.
Like gas.
Yeah, it was like you got your gas
and then you got your oil.
You gotta take care of both of them.
But it isn't as big of an
issue anymore, I don't think
Well, I mean you get a more modern car
and this got more lights
that tell you stuff
and they blink and like...
I gotta put washer fluid in my car.
It's bugging me about that.
Oh, that's good.
I mean better to be bugged
than to be on the side of the road
without washer fluid.
And wipe off the bugs.
But I have developed a habit of
whenever I go to get in my car,
I always look at the tires.
Mm-hmm.
I think one time,
I realized I've been driving
and one of my tires was really flat,
many many years ago
and it kinda burned me.
Well, the cars to tell you that now too.
They do, yeah,
if you get a fancy one.
But it's always nice to just
before you get in your vehicle,
just walk around it once.
Give it the auto.
Like it's a rental.
The rental car walk around,
look at those tires,
make sure there's nothing dragging.
You know, I found a screw in my tire,
the other day doing this.
Yeah, that's a pre preemptive catch.
You can drive to the place
and have them plug it.
They plugged it up.
Good old shell,
thevelvethook.
Here's this piece of advice.
"You can't control how people act
but you can can control..."
Did I just say can can?
Yeah, you kinda did.
We all knew what you meant.
"You can't control how people act,
but you can control how you react.
This has helped me so many times in life
when deciding how to
respond in situations.
And it's made me more aware
of when I'm letting my
reactions overtake me.
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
Control is such a big part of my psychy,
that--
I'm aware of this.
This type of advice
is just great for me.
I find when I'm really
anxious it's because,
I want something to be a certain
way but I feel powerless.
And if I can just parse between
what I can actually impact,
and what I have no control over,
it really does help me.
Oh Link you're talking about
the prayer for Serenity
that many of you already know.
Yeah, give it to me.
God grant me the serenity to accept--
Can you sing it?
Or chant it a monkish kind of way,
I don't know whatever you think is--
♪God grant me the serenity ♪
♪To accept the things I cannot change ♪
♪The courage to change the things I can ♪
♪And the wisdom to know the difference♪
I didn't know that that thing went on.
That's only a third of it.
That's the only part
that you need to know in this context.
Grant me the serenity to change,
I got to read it again
'cause I was so distracted.
I just sang it though.
See if I can remember it.
Okay, I'll see if I can remember it.
I was just thinking about
that horrible melody.
I think that that was pretty good
for like pulling monk melody,
God grant me the
Straight out of the air.
Grant me the serenity to accept
these things that cannot change
but change the things I can accept.
Accept the things I cannot change
the courage to change the things I can
and the wisdom to know the difference.
So that's the parsing
that you're talking about.
Mm-hmm.
And,
boy, man, what if everybody..
I mean, first of all,
it's one thing to even to know that
you should be doing this.
I just remembered something,
I gotta get my laptop.
'Cause I wrote something.
I was reflecting on this,
and I thought I came up with something,
and I wrote it down
and then I went back to look at it.
You rederive this the Serenity Prayer?
This is how I wrote it
in my digital journal.
Some things you just can't change.
Other things you can.
Some things you think you
can change, but can't.
And some things you don't
think you could have changed,
but you could have.
Those are the sad ones.
I mean, you know I'm not--
I mean, would you like me to sing that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
here it is.
Okay, I can sing this,
I can do that.
Okay, here we go.
And don't read any of that other stuff.
Yeah yeah.
'Cause this my
freakin journal.
I see it just as thoughts, okay.
♪Some things you just can't change♪
♪ Other things you can♪
Good.
♪Some things you think you can change ♪
♪But you can't ♪
♪And some things you don't
think you could have changed ♪
♪But you could have ♪
♪Those are those sad♪
I'm being a vulnerable man,
I'm sharing my journal--
♪ Those are the sad ones♪
I think maybe just a just a perfectionist
like thinking.
There's a lot of thinking
going on in that.
A lot too much to say.
But the worst thing is not thinking
you could change something
and then you can't,
but thinking you couldn't
change something, and you could.
I think that may be torture for me.
No, because once it's happened,
you can't go back and change it.
I know, I'm not talking
about things in the past.
It says you could have.
You could have,
you could have in the past.
Yes, and that's sad.
That's bad.
Those are the sad ones.
Sitting around and thinking about
what you could have done differently?
♪Those are the sad ones♪
But I'm thinking about the next thing.
It's like, man,
I can't do anything about this.
But if you could have
done something about it,
but you convinced yourself
you couldn't, that's sad.
That's the saddest.
Yeah.
That's sadder than trying
and not being able to change
but that's just futile.
Well, I read a book that was...
I was gonna make it a wreck at some point,
maybe I will in the future,
but it's your wrecked today.
I think it was called The
Courage to be Disliked.
And it was all about adlerian psychology,
I think that guy's name was Joseph Adler,
but he was basically
a guy back in the time
of Freud and Young.
What ended up happening
is Freudian psychology,
ended up kinda winning out,
in terms of the way
people think about things,
but there was this guy,
Mm-hmm.
I guess, Joseph Adler,
who thought differently about things
and he had this mentality,
it's pretty fascinating,
I don't even know what I think about it.
But anyway, one of the
principles in this book,
is this idea of,
in every situation,
you basically sort of revisit this parsing
that you're talking about.
This idea that,
"I can only control myself.
I can only control my
actions, my reactions."
And I wish I could remember
the term that he used.
Again, I was gonna go
back and look at this
before I ever talked about
it and recommended it.
I hate doing this but,
there was just this idea of
what we have such a tendency to do
is we just get confused with
what our work is, right?
And this especially
relates to other people,
and you get into these
very codependent situations
where you're just like,
"If this person would
just do this thing right."
Mm-hmm.
If this person would
just react or react or behave in this way,
then I would be okay.
And then when you can
kinda just release yourself
from that trying to get people
to do what you want them to do,
what you expect them
to do, and realize that
the only sovereignty I
have is over my own actions
and it's just very freeing.
And it's so difficult
because there is this,
we do believe that we can change people,
and it's tough because there
are people who specialize
in helping people change, right?
So if you think about my
therapist talking to me--
Well, you might can change people,
but you can't control people.
Well the classic analogy,
you can lead a horse to water,
but you can't make them drink.
So I do think that we
get all the way sometimes
and we just want to
force someone's action.
But as...
It makes me think of as what?
As shall demonstrates,
if you focus on the way that you react,
you'll be a lot happier.
As George Strait saying,
"You can lead a heart to love
but you can't make it fall."
And I always thought that
was a very clunky song.
I mean, yeah, I get it,
you're kind of--
But can't make it fall.
You can't make someone
fall in love with you.
Again, it's very clunky,
I'm not a fan.
I think Bonnie Raitt said it much better.
Oh, yeah, that's a good song.
I can't make you love me if you don't.
Yeah.
Boy, that's a good song.
That's her best.
Well, I'm not gonna say it's her best.
That's Bonnie Raitt's best song.
Oh, gosh.
Name a second Bonnie Raitt's song.
Exactly.
Let's give him something to talk about.
Actually, you know what?
That's not as good.
No as good man.
You know what?
I have a sense that
there's some Bonnie Raitt
that we don't know about
that's really good.
Some second rate Bonnie Raitt?
There's some first rate Bonnie Raitt.
So don't you be talking about,
if you can't even name two
songs what her best song is.
♪Turn down the lights♪
I mean, it's so good man.
It's a great song.
Everything about it it's just perfect.
Mark Cohen's best song is
not walking in Memphis,
and that's I don't want you--
Clearly.
I don't want you to make that mistake
with Bonnie Raitt.
Hold on Mark Cohen's
walking in Memphis is not even
in Mark Cohen's top 15 songs.
Exactly.
But I think you're
making a walking Memphis,
you're walking in Memphis right now.
I'm walking in Bonnie Raitt.
I'm walking down Bonnie Raitt way,
and I've missed a turn.
Kaesha Johnson.
Maybe it's Kaesha Johnson.
"I watched a TED talk by Celeste Headlee
on how to have a good conversation."
Oh, okay, I like this.
"My favorite piece of
advice she gives was,
enter every conversation,
assuming you have something to learn.
I highly recommend this TED Talk.
It's on YouTube.
#EarBiscuits."
Enter every conversation,
assuming you have something
to learn, humility,
In light of what's going on,
and I've really tried to
with the Black Lives Matter movement,
right now just really say,
" I'm gonna listen,
I'm gonna learn,
and I'm gonna make applications.
It's really top of mind
for me in that way,
but it's so important in general.
I think it's not instinctive,
it's instinctive to just react and okay.
If someone's saying something
that could impact me
or reflect on me or is someone
making an assertion about me,
and then you instinctively take that in
and then can react defensively.
It's hard to walk a mile
in someone else's shoes,
it takes practice to have
that kind of mindset.
To step out of yourself
and whatever it is,
whatever issue impacts me and saying,
"Okay, what is this person really saying?
What can I learn in this conversation?"
I think we've talked about how
we go in the party settings,
and we're interacting with people
and you're having these
little conversations,
and the ones that are the
most stimulating to us
are the ones that's like,
when we have a mindset of,
when somebody tells me what they do,
if you pump a septic tank,
or you're writing blockbuster films,
we should be able to have
an engaging conversation
with each person.
And I think it's because,
it's a little bit of this mentality of,
there's always a question to ask,
there's always something to be learned.
Mm-hmm.
It's like anybody can say,
"I'm so and so,
or I do this on Reddit,
ask me anything."
And underneath you will
find rewarding conversations
when people have that mindset.
It's rewarding for everybody.
People feel valued,
they'll feel they feel heard,
and you you can learn something.
You can learn something
from a total asshole.
Mm-hmm, well I do think
that this is so applicable.
we're just in the latest sort of
polarizing national issue, right?
Mm-hmm.
This has been going on
for a long time now.
The dream of the internet
connecting people resulted in
the internet dividing people
because now there's this
democratization of information,
and people have separated into
these information bubbles.
And you only talk with
people who agree with you,
and then when you do
get into these occasions
where you have a conversation with someone
that you disagree with,
the goal is not to find the truth
between your two perspectives,
the goal is to entrench yourself
and defend your position at all costs,
and I'm guilty of it.
Like you said, it's just
kind of human nature.
I'm thinking about,
I don't know exactly how this relates,
but this made me think of
this quote from Fight Club.
Because I just watched Fight
Club recently with Locke.
Rule number one.
Don't talk about Fight Club.
Rule number two.
Rule number three.
Something about if you're new here,
you have to fight.
If you're first...
I think rule number four
is if your first time
you have to fight.
I think rule number three is,
the fighting goes until one person stops
or something like that.
I think there's only four.
I don't have any rules are.
That wasn't where I was gonna go,
but the thing that I realized,
and this is true, David
Fincher movies in general,
I actually kind of regretted
not putting Fight Club
on my top 10 list after watching it.
I don't know if it would
have made the top 10 but
you just forget how many
good lines are in his movies.
I mean, just disclaimer,
It's very visceral and violent movie.
Could be very disturbing
for certain people.
Yeah.
But--
It's not for everyone.
One of the things that
Brad Pitt's character
says in the movie is,
"You know when you're dying,
people really really listen to you,
instead of just waiting
for their turn to talk."
Mm-hmm.
And I'm not really talking
about the dying part,
but talking about just the
default of humans, which is,
and I'm super guilty of this.
Just waiting for my turn to talk, right?
You just like,
Oh, I got some.
And it's one thing for it that
just happened in the context
of a friendship or like
people hanging out,
where it's just like,
"Oh, now we're telling
poop yourself stories,
all right, I got mine.'
Yeah.
And those are fun.
Those stories are fun,
but also that that kinda
conversation can be fun,
but I think especially
when you're talking about something
that you have a disagreement about.
There's a concept that I heard
somebody described one time,
what typically happens online,
which is the straw man,
which is, you mischaracterize
someone's argument
and you distill it down to
something that you can easily
Burn down.
Take out, yeah.
But the opposite of that,
I think is called iron manning?
I don't know,
something like that.
Okay.
But it's like,
I'm going to understand and be
able to state your position,
in the most defensible
way I can think of, right?
I'm gonna give you the
benefit of the doubt,
I'm gonna try to capture the
essence of what you're saying
in a way that you can agree with.
So that then when I disagree with it,
you can hear my disagreement,
because you know you've been heard.
Yeah, but also,
there's just something about
just making yourself willing
to go through the process
of being like, okay, before I
just go into my talking points
and break out my ideology,
I am going to understand
and be able to say things like,
"So you're saying,
if I'm hearing you correctly,
you're saying this, this and this
and they say no,
that's not what I'm saying."
Keep listening.
Mm-hmm.
And then if you can
finally get to
your saying this and this,
yes.
Even if you disagree,
there's progress that's been made.
There's some kind of common ground
'cause you've at least agreed
to have a rational
conversation about something.
Yeah.
And that's just such a
difficult thing to do.
Yeah, I mean, I quoted George Strait,
now I'll quote Clint Black.
♪Put yourself in my shoes♪
Right.
♪Walk a mile for me♪
Yeah.
♪I'll put myself in your shoes ♪
♪And maybe then we'd see♪
That if you put yourself in my shoes,
you'd have some sympathy.
And if I put myself in your shoes,
I'd walk right back to me.
'Cause it's a love story.
It's a relationship.
That's a good song,
that is a good song.
Yeah.
I don't know.
He's got a new album,
I'm not gonna listen to it.
Clint Black does?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know,
Ever since he was on the apprentice.
Yeah, I have a different.
It's like, once I saw Clint
Black unplugged completely.
Right.
Yeah, okay all right.
Ah, yeah.
And it has nothing to do
with Trump or the apprentice.
Right.
It's just seeing
who Clint Black is.
It's not like I don't
like him necessarily,
It's just he isn't the person that
his songs made him out to be.
Do you get what I'm saying?
Those first two albums,
Killin' Time and I think it's
Put Yourself in My Shoes.
And was he writing the songs?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he wrote some good
songs on those two albums.
Beth Ann Smith says,
"After my grandfather died,
my mom found a piece of paper
tucked in the phonebook."
Well that's classic.
Having a note tucked in a phone book.
Yeah.
Man, remember phone books?
You can still get them.
Sometimes I'll drop them
off in your driveway.
"He had written and then
tucked into the notebook.
Today invest in someone else's happiness"
And then Beth Ann said,
"I think about those words
almost every single day."
I love the fact that Beth
Ann that you can carry
this meaningful part
of your grandfather with you at all times.
And I picture him writing that
and it was kind of a note to self.
He probably went to the phone book a lot.
We forget how often you
went to the phone book.
Every time you had to get
in contact with somebody,
I mean, I had certain numbers memorized,
and then you had,
with the advent of the speed dial,
but a lot of times you would,
even as kids,
we would go to the phonebook a lot.
Not just for people, but for places.
Oh, yeah.
The Yellow Pages man.
The yellow part in the back.
You talk about Yelp.
The Yellow Pages was the Yelp.
You had to judge a plumber by his ad.
Yeah and there were no reviews.
It was just the number part.
It was like does this plumber look smart?
So whenever he was interacting,
let's think about this.
He was about to make a phone call,
he was about to have an
interaction with somebody,
it could be a business,
it could be a loved one,
It could be a complete stranger.
Someone where he needed
to accomplish something.
In some way,
he was gonna make a phone call to do that.
Right.
And then right there in front of him
was his reminder to himself.
"Invest in someone else's happiness."
And here's an opportunity right now.
It can be something as simple as,
"I'm calling you for this reason A,
but by the way B,
I can say a little something
to make you happy."
I can crack a joke,
I can be smiling on the phone
and now you can feel it.
It might just change the tone
of the way that you communicate.
Yeah.
The thing that it makes me think about is,
I feel like I know nothing
about Beth Ann's grandfather, right?
I've never met the man.
All I know is that he put
this note into a phonebook.
Yeah.
But I know a lot about him
because of that, right?
Yeah.
I know that whether he was
like this his entire life,
or he came to the
conclusion later in life,
that this is actually where his happiness,
his true happiness lied, right?
Is in investing in
somebody else's happiness.
And man, it's such good advice
because everybody needs it,
and we're all very naturally
resistant to understanding that
because your natural impulse is to invest
in your own happiness, right?
It's to look out for yourself.
It's to think about your circumstances.
But we talked about the whole
the idea of the first mountain
and the second mountain.
The first mountain in life being about
you getting to the top of
whatever your goals are.
Mm-hmm.
And then either you
fall off that mountain,
or you get to the top.
This is that David Brooks book,
and then you're like,
"Oh, there's another mountain
I should have been on."
And that's the mountain of
investing in other people.
And if you can get there at some point,
and make your life where it
shifts from your interest.
That can be very
Sounds like it happened
with her grandfather.
Rewarding.
And the phrase,
"pay it forward" comes to mind.
The thing that I don't love about that is
it implies that you've
received something good,
and now it's a reminder to give it.
I shouldn't pick it apart.
I'm sure it's a great phrase,
and is a good mantra,
but the thing I like about this is,
It's not contingent on your experience
to invest in someone else's happiness.
But when you do benefit from
someone enriching your life,
I do think it's a good trigger to say,
"How can I take this
experience that was given to me
and regift it?
Or also gift it?"
'Cause I don't even have
to give up my experience
to give another one.
But it's interesting here,
it doesn't say,
"today make someone happy."
He says, "today, invest in
someone else's happiness."
Mm-hmm.
I think a lot of times
there are people who,
it would be a magical ability
to just make everybody happy.
I mean, that's just the work of clowns.
Some good clowns.
I would say the small
percentage of clowns.
Right.
I'm sorry clowns.
This is just the way it is.
But an investment in to
me, it makes me think that,
even if you can't make
someone happy in the moment,
you can do something that
at least sow the seed
of happiness down the road for them so.
Well and also in the context of,
I mean, he's got it in the phonebook,
and we're talking about it
in the context with like,
people that you interact with,
acquaintances or whatever.
But I also think about it in terms of
your closest relationships
that you have, right so.
Mm-hmm
I think about the days that I get home.
It's funny,
I was thinking about getting home too,
because we haven't been getting home.
Right.
'Cause we've been at home so much
but we're starting to do that.
Yeah, and so yeah.
So I think about it more.
I get home and I walk into the house,
I see Jessie.
And I think that a lot of times,
my disposition is how is her presence
or something that she says.
Can she say or do something
that makes me okay
with something that
happened to me today, right?
Like I'm coming into the house,
thinking about what I can get from her.
Part of it is the fact that
Barbara greets me at the door,
and Barbara is all about
what she can give to me.
You're too invest...
Yeah, you're willing to
receive an investment
in your happiness.
But if I went in and my mentality was
regardless of how bad my day was,
I'm going in with the mindset of like,
invest in her happiness.
And again, you can actually
do it for selfish reasons,
just to be completely transparent.
Because ultimately the
weird thing about this is,
you kind of go full circle,
and it's just like,
this will make you happier.
I think that's the beauty of it.
Yeah.
I don't think that's the--
That's not the motivation,
I'm just saying.
But the net result is,
if you go in with that, surprise surprise,
you will end up being happier ultimately.
Yeah, and I think because
we are getting out more
than our families are,
we're in here connecting,
having this conversation,
this is an investment
in our happiness, right?
Mm-hmm.
We're getting built up in a way.
They're not leaving the
house as much as we are.
So when we when we go
back to our families,
I'm bringing an energy
that is hard to just create
when you're at home all the time.
Yeah.
So starting to have more of
that mentality I think itself.
Boy, all of this...
I thank you for sharing all this advice.
Yeah, there's more that we can talk about,
maybe we'll talk about another time.
Man these farts are really smelling good.
Yeah, see I just don't like the analogy.
I'm gonna make a recommendation because
wreck baby wreck baby 123 is that time,
is the end of the episode.
I wanna recommend that you listen
to Strange Fruit by Billie Holiday.
I didn't know about this song.
Time call...
In 1999 Time called this song,
Time magazine said Strange Fruit was
the best song of the century.
They named it that at
the turn of the century.
Was recorded by Billie Holiday in 1939.
It was written by Abel
Meeropol, two years earlier.
It protests the lynching
of black Americans
with lyrics that compare the
victims to the fruit of trees.
And if you want to read about all this,
just go to the Wikipedia,
that's where I'm getting this information,
but it's a powerful song.
In this time,
it puts yourself in the shoes of someone
looking at a photograph of a lynching
that happened in Indiana
Mm-hmm.
On August 7 1930.
Upwards of 5000 black Americans died
as a result of lynching.
And there are photographs of people...
There are postcards
Yeah.
Of people celebrating and
having picnics in the presence
of black people being hung from trees.
Mm-hmm.
As if it's like,
look at the great thing that we did,
It's absolutely horrifying.
But through this song,
It turned out to be Billy
Holiday's, most popular song
and it was sold over a million records.
And, it was it was a huge,
it was a huge risk in her career.
Of course, she was advised not to do it.
She was very relegated,
regulated in the way she could do it,
she had to be let out of
her recording contract
to record this song as an exception.
Mm-hmm.
And then it became her most popular song,
it's extremely moving.
It's another way to stare into the face of
the horror of racism
and deal with it.
Oh, it's kind of a small example of
what I see so often online
when anybody who's an artist
of any kind, entertainer
says anything with conviction
that might be interpreted as political.
There's this shut up and sing.
Shut up and dance.
Shut up and we'll do
whatever it is that you do.
Mm-hmm.
And I love it when an artist takes that
and actually turns it back
on the people who say that
and through their art
does something that is..
that paints the picture in a stark
and sort of heart wrenching way.
Yeah, this is on
the playlist that Brit and I created,
If you don't know, give or take,
every week on Saturday night
we do a listening party for each other
with this different themes
and we did a theme of songs for change.
This is on that playlist.
So you can go to my Instagram,
and click on the igtvtab and
see all of those episodes
but specifically this one.
Go to my Spotify.
I got all the songs up.
This is your laptop, I
didn't mean to close it.
No, I'll be okay.
Go to my spot...
You don't need it?
There you go, It's gone.
I got all types of playlists.
Now you're shouting out your Spotify.
You can't get on me about shouting out,
I haven't shouted out my stuff in a long.
I only did it so that you would say that.
Strange Fruit but Billie Holiday,
that's really what you need to listen to.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for the advice
that was given to you
that then you shared with us
and hopefully the conversation
about it spread all the love
and the advice around
in all the right places.
Invest in someone's happiness today.
Is what you make it.
We'll talk at you in a few weeks.
Enjoy the break from us,
but don't forget about us.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.